il est l'heure d'ouvrir notre journal
des élections avec vous lilian melet il
ne mènera dans trois semaines au premier
tour de ces départementale oui c'est un
moment politique assez nouveau avec un
double phénomène d'abord un redécoupage
des cantons qui n'avait pas bougé depuis
très longtemps et puis un mode de
scrutin complètement nouveau en france
des binômes de candidats un homme une
femme parité obligatoire pour chaque
canton
la carte des cantons avait peu changé
depuis napoléon en 1801 le gouvernement
a décidé de la remodeler les cantons ont
été regroupés et leur nombre a été
divisé par deux de 4050 50 ans on passe
à 2074 ont fait des cantons plus gros
pour qu'on sorte d'un millefeuille et
d'un émiettement extrêmement puissant
qui est un des méfaits un des reproches
qui est fait au système politico
administratif français il faut remodeler
régulièrement les cantons comme les
circonscriptions pour tenir compte des
évolutions démographiques à un
redécoupage qui ne changent pas le
nombre de conseillers départementaux
puisque vous en élire et deux par canton
mais la plus grande innovation c'est que
vous n'allez plus voter pour un candidat
mais pour un binôme obligatoirement
hommes femmes
les suppléants aussi devront respecter
cette mixité
on parle depuis très longtemps de la
parité mais elle ne se fait pas ou très
difficilement dans le mode de scrutin va
imposer une forme de parité puisqu'on
aura à chaque fois un binôme hommes
femmes avec cette parité totale
les assemblées départementales auront
autant d'hommes que de femmes
c'est une première actuellement
seulement 14% des conseillers généraux
sont des femmes
et à trois semaines du scrutin les liant
c'est le moment des bilans moment des
bilans et des classements à la chaîne
économique bfm business vient d'établir
le classement des départements les mieux
gérées sur sept critères c'est assez
complet et le meilleur c'est le morbihan
en milieu de tableau pour la bourgogne
ou gauche et droite sont dos à dos
saône-et-loire 44e et côte-d'or 47e et
puis dans les tréfonds du classement
c'est là que ça se gâte la nièvre et 75e
et l'yonne 80e c'est à dire avant
dernière inutile de dire que ce
classement on en cause beaucoup dans
l'yonne
en ce moment nous intéresserons un
compte en particulier
focus sur brazey-en-plaine oui nous
avons sélectionné une quinzaine de
cantons une quinzaine d'histoire et de
situations locales qui permettent de
comprendre les enjeux de ces élections
on parlait de redécoupage tout à l'heure
et bien le nouveau canton de brazey
réunit deux anciens cantons seraient
saint jean de losne 38 communes des
communes essentiellement rural marqué
depuis dix ans par une forte progression
du front national aux européennes il est
arrivé en tête dans 37 communes sur 38
anne berger
tiphaine piper
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas si emmanuel
points la candidate de la majorité
départementale vient voir les pompiers
avec son colistier gilles delepau maire
de brazey en plaine et leurs suppléants
c'est d'abord pour s'inquiéter du moral
des troupes c'est des gens qui prennent
sur leur temps de travail ou sur leur
temps de repos et qui font les deux en
même temps là la conseillère générale
sortante est là aussi pour faire le
bilan de l'action départementale pour le
canton de brazey c'est plus de 6
millions 7 qui ont été versés aux
communes
indépendamment des compétences directes
de l'investissement direct vous pouvez
faire le département et puis
effectivement un gros programme de
rénovation sur les 10 en 2014 nous avons
fait le centre de saint jean de losne
cette année c'est celui de brazey et
l'an prochain à une nouvelle caserne à
seurre l'action dans la continuité pour
une candidate qui lance un appel aux
électeurs
il faut que les gens ne se trompe pas de
rendez vous là on est là pour une
élection qui concerne le territoire pour
défendre le territoire une vision du
territoire lui deux casquettes de
facteurs pour alain becquet et sa
colistière chantalou vrai mais un
soutien celui du conseiller général
sortant socialiste de l'ancien canton de
saint jean de losne roger ganée et une
seule préoccupation
on est sur un canton droit en plein avec
un taux moyen de chômage d'environ 15%
donc effectivement on peut mettre tout
les choses en place qu'on veut mais il
ya eu la première des priorités pour moi
personnellement c'est l'emploi de par ma
profession et en tant que responsable
pri entreprise moi je sais naturellement
je connais les problématiques
d'entreprise et aujourd'hui on a besoin
est à leurs côtés
l'un des problèmes du canton une main
d'oeuvre locale peut qualifier but aura
deux bateaux dans le coin
même lui faudra plus de gens formés sur
les bords de saône le développement du
tourisme fluvial n'a pas profité à tout
le monde 22% de chômage sur saint jean
de losne où le vote fn n'en finit pas de
grimper et à qui est à droite comme à
gauche moi j'ai envie de dire aux aînés
aux jeunes du territoire à toute la
population
ne désespérez pas il faut qu'on se bat
sur le terrain et ça c'est très clair
nous on connaît le terrain
un terrain où les candidats du front
national d'amiens compta et christelle
bernier compte bien s'imposer et gagner
leur siège à l'assemblée départementale
on va le 22 mars et le 29 mars un peu
raboté donc ici on a un gros réservoir
un gros vivier de d'électeurs front
national je pense qu'ici on est vraiment
sur des terres front national est on est
on
on peut penser que avoir fait 49 % en
vu le contexte national actuel on fera
51 en 2015
chaque main serré ça va compter un final
dans les yeux quand cette année on va
pas perdre élections pour 40 voir ici
les candidats fn cren plus l'abstention
que leurs adversaires ne savent pas trop
où ils vont ils vont souffrir de cette
malheureusement ou heureusement pour
nous avons souffert cette image
nationale de leurs deux parties portent
les quais de la saône respire encore le
calme et la sérénité mais tout le monde
le sait les apparences sont parfois
trompeuses et le débat de la boe libre
samedi à 11 heures sera justement
consacré au département de la côte d'or
et demain nous irons dans le canton de
corbigny au coeur de la nièvre
ces élections dignes on peut les suivre
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est ce que
vous faites
il y avait du sérieux et du moins
sérieux en commençant par le fameux
classement des départements dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure repris entre
autres par le candidat socialiste de
sens pascal simon qui ne portent pas la
chaîne dans son coeur mais qui ne
néglige pas pour autant l'argument dans
l'yonne encore une visite à la ferme
pour le député ump guillaume larrivé aux
côtés du président hu dei andré villiers
l'entente des droites dans l'yonne
photos à l'appui
et puis dans l'yonne encore ce n'est pas
encore la bataille électorale finale
mais c'est déjà la guerre des étoiles
dans les rues de migennes en fête le
carnaval avec une photo prise par le
maire et candidat ump françois boucher
photo re tweeté par un candidat
socialiste comme quoi le carnaval ça
peut réunir tout le monde
et même si elle n'intéresse pas grand
monde la campagne elle a bien débuté en
porte à porte sur les marchés avec le
duo ump de dijon iv qui se donne du
courage pour une nouvelle semaine de
campagne et un selphy au soleil pour
l'équipe socialiste du même canton le
canton de dijon iv
cette équipe qui a fait du sport ce
week-end pour garder la forme et il va
leur en falloir et nous en falloir de la
forme jusqu'au premier tour le 22 mars
en attendant on se retrouve demain pour
de nouveaux cantons et de nouvelles
informations des réseaux sociaux
merci lilian à retrouver toute
l'actualité de ce scrutin également sur
notre site internet vous trouverez en
haut de page un onglet spécial
départementale consultez également notre
blog politique